[Musique]
ce chant clair vosgien non sinon la
victoire du moins la revanche du fumier
sur l'or noir ou plus exactement la
revanche du gaz méthane provenant de la
terre natation du purin depuis près d'un
quart de siècle monsieur andré chapuis
de xertigny utilisent cet original
combustible temps pour faire sa cuisine
que pour chauffer son logement il
envisage aussi de raccorder
prochainement à ce gaz de fumier un
chauffe-eau de salle de bain la matière
première provient de la litière d'une
vingtaine de vaches
partie des cuves en ciment
[Musique]
le fonctionnement de l'installation de
monsieur chappuis est des plus simples
elle se compose de trois cuves en ciment
de 8 mètres cubes chacune sécu sont
remplies de fumier en moyenne une fois
par mois pendant une semaine le fumier
quotidiennement arrosé afin d'activer la
fermentation qui donnera naissance au
purin et au méthane un essai de brûlage
sera alors effectuée au bec d'une des
cuves puis le méthane gagnera le
gazomètre où la cloche métallique lui
assurera une pression convenable chacune
a une autonomie journalière d'environ 4
mètres cubes seul inconvénient les trop
grands froids qui risque de freiner la
fermentation
or depuis 20 ans votre cuisine ou faites
votre chauffage à partir du gaz du
fumier ça vous coûte absolument
rien juste le travail de remplir les
cuves innée mais
et sur le plan de la culture c'est
encore un autre avantage
le fumier il augmente d'un tiers de sa
valeur dire que la zone ne s'échappe
absolument plus là bah oui c'est un
engrais concentré oui j'aime autant vous
regarde parce que il a un avantage qui
n'attirent pas de risque d'explosion
une n'est pas toxique
vous pouvez à l'affairé je vais enfin
pouvoir
[Musique]